DID YOU KNOW THAT MORE THAN HALF
THE COUNTRY ARE WOMEN?
IT'S TRUE.
AND YET, SOMEHOW, MORE THAN HALF
THE MONEY GOES TO MEN.
>> ACCORDING TO THE CENSUS
BUREAU, WOMEN EARN 78 CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR MADE MY MEN.
>> A NEW STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
INSTITUTE FOR WOMEN'S POLICY
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT AMERICAN
WOMEN WON'T SEE EQUAL PAY UNTIL
2058.
>> Jon: RIGHT AROUND THE TIME
SCIENTISTS PREDICT THE EARTH
WILL COMPLETELY BE COVERED IN
WATER.
I HOPE YOUR PRECIOUS MONEY
FLOATS, LADIES.
FOR MORE, WE'RE JOINED BY
SENIOR WOMEN'S ISSUES
CORRESPONDENT KRISTEN SCHAAL.
KRISTEN!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
KRISTEN.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: THIS NEWS I HAVE JUST
RELAYED IT SEEMS BLEAK.
>> WHAT?
NO, THIS IS INCREDIBLE NEWS!
TONIGHT WE'RE GONNA PARTY LIKE
IT'S 2058!
DRINKS ON ME!
HEY, CAN I BORROW YOUR CREDIT
CARD?
CAUSE I'M NOT GOING TO GET PAY
EQUALITY FOR A WHILE.
IT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Jon: NOW, HERE'S WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SO LONG.
THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW WHAT, I
KNOW HOW TO SOLVE THIS.
LET'S PAY WOMEN THE SAME AS MEN!
COME ON!
COME ON, YEAH!
LET'S   DO IT!
YOU'RE WELCOME, LADIES!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> YOU DID IT, JON!
>> Jon: YEAH! WHOO!
WE SHOULD PASS A LAW! A LAW!
>> LIKE SOME SORT OF EQUAL PAY
ACT LAW!
YEAH!
>> Jon: BOOM!
>> LIKE THE ONE KENNEDY ALREADY
SIGNED IN 1963.
GREAT IDEA, JON.
HEY, JON, YOU HEARD OF THESE
FOUR MOP-TOPS OUT OF LIVERPOOL?
I THINK THEY'RE GONNA BE BIG!
>> Jon: WE DID, WE DID? WE
PASSED THAT EQUAL PAY LAW?
WELL WHAT WAS THE LILLY
LEDBETTER ACT A FEW YEARS AGO.
WHAT WAS --
>> WELL, THAT JUST MADE IT
EASIER TO SUE THE JERKS
VIOLATING THE 1963 LAW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ASSUMED THAT LAW
WAS JUST FOR SHOW.
>> Jon: BUT STILL, THAT'S
GREAT.
WE GOT EQUAL PAY! AND WE GOT THE
LAW THAT YOU CAN SUE FOR EQUAL
PAY, SO GREAT... KRISTEN
SCHAAL, EVERYBODY!
THAT WAS A SHORT PIECE, BUT
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
THAT'S TERRIFIC, EVERYBODY TAKE
CARE AND --
>> NO! STOP!
WE'RE NOT DONE HERE!
CAMERA!... YOU STAY ON ME.
YOU, LOCK THE DOORS!
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWO WAGE GAPS.
THERE YOU ARE!
>> Jon: WHAT!
YES!
ONE OF YOUR CLASSIC, OH, HEY,
LADY, HERE'S YOUR PAYCHECK, UH,
WAIT ONE SECOND...
OH, YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
>> Jon: WAIT, WHY DID YOU RIP
SOME OF IT?
>> OH, I DON'T KNOW, YOUR
CHROMOSOMES, FELT LIKE IT.
BUT IT GETS WORSE!
>> Jon: WHAT? WORSE THAN THIS?
YES, THE OTHER MORE MYSTERIOUS
WAGE GAP. THE SYSTEMIC ONE.
>> Jon: SYSTEMIC, THAT IS A
DIFFICULT --
>> SYSTEMIC. IT'S A COMPLICATED
WORD.
>> Jon: YOU CAN SAY THE
SYSTEM-IC OR SYSTEMIC!
>> BOTH OF THEM, GROSS!
>> Jon: IT'S BAR-BAR --
>> IC!
>> Jon: YES! SURE!
>> YES, YES. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT,
OBVIOUSLY, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE SYSTEM THAT PRINTS THE
PAYCHECKS WRONG.
>> OH JON, YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT,
DO YOU?
>> Jon: NO, I'M A DUDE.
>> SOCIETY MAKES IT EASIER FOR
MEN TO GO INTO HIGHER PAYING
JOBS AND SUPPORTS THEM MORE WHEN
THEY GET THEM.
>> Jon: SO THEN ALL WE HAVE
TO DO IS PROVIDE WOMEN
BETTER CHILDCARE OPTIONS,
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
CHANGE ALL THE MESSAGING IN
MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT,
I MEAN, HOW COMPLICATED
REALLY COULD THIS BE?
>> RIGHT, NOT VERY COMPLICATED.
BUT HERE ARE SOME APPARENTLY
LESS COMPLICATED THINGS
THAT ARE GOING TO HAPPEN BEFORE
THEN.
>> MAKERS
OF A GROUND BREAKING FLYING CAR
SAY IT WILL GO ON SALE IN 2017.
>> NASA IS WORKING REALLY HARD
TO GET PEOPLE OUT TO THE PLANET
MARS BY THE YEAR 2030.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE FLYING CARS
ON MARS 28 YEARS BEFORE
WOMEN --
>> Jon: NO, THAT'S NOT, THEY'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT (BLEEP)
FOREVER! THE MARS AND THE FLYING
CARS, OH WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE JET PACKS AND DINNER IN A
PILL.
I'VE SEEN THE JETSONS! THIS IS
ALL BULL (BLEEP).
GIVE ME SOMETHING REAL!
>> ALL RIGHT, NOT REAL
ENOUGH? HOW'S THIS FOR REAL?
>> 3D PRINTERS CAN MAKE SOME
AMAZING THINGS THESE DAYS.
ONE MAN SAYS THAT, TEN YEARS
FROM NOW, HE WILL BE ABLE TO
PRINT AN ENTIRE HUMAN HEART.
>> Jon: HOLY (BLEEP).
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: YOU'RE TELLING ME WE'RE
GOING TO PRINT A HUMAN HEART OUT
OF A XEROX MACHINE BEFORE
WOMEN GET PAY EQUALITY?
>> NO, I'M TELLING YOU WE'RE
GOING TO PRINT HUMAN HEARTS OUT
OF XEROX MACHINES 30 YEARS
BEFORE WOMEN GET PAY EQUALITY!
AT THIS POINT WE'D BE BETTER OFF
PRINTING A 3-D PENIS, SLAPPING
IT ON THE BANK COUNTER AND
SAYING HEY SOCIETY,
(BLEEP) YOU, PAY ME.